part of being in the tech community
means that things are unpredictable
and Big Ideas happen fast and you just
have to go go go go go
creativity is at its best when people
with different ideas and different
expertise come together when we started
we shared a meal we had surprisingly
little knowledge about pretty much
everything the reason why we stand where
we stand right now is because we found
the people that are willing to
collaborate with us collaboration was
not necessary it was essential or your
partners are the most important part of
the puzzle we have been able to work
together with those hotel partners and
they have responded in a massive wave
since I was a child I always wanted to
create something that creates an impact
on thousands of people I found that with
technology and collaboration we could do
it we are this new Internet age what's
so exciting is we get to be the first to
make a difference and we get to harness
that power behind every successful
person is a group of people making it
happen helping to organize and put
things together and think about things
I've memorized we've got coders
filmmakers linguists product designers
in a crazy Italian bus driver we've got
a whole community of people around
Europe participating in the creation of
this video dictionary of all Europe's
language you know for elements of the
baseball we found out that there are 20
times as many people that have
smartphones than hungry children and
jeremy'll want to make it as easy as
possible for people to do good whenever
they want wherever they are India on one
side had 3 million rooms available on
the other side there was half a billion
people who were to stay I realized that
there was a huge amount of problem in
being able to connect both of these
people our aspiration was saying we will
solve it which is why for 3 months
almost every day I would stay in a new
motel a guest house a service apartment
and with the use of technology we can
create great games that will help kids
be smarter every day today we feel that
there are no barriers we can have anyone
from all over the world be working with
us and that is nice
I am the generation that was the first
to grow up with technology and so I
wanted to use technology to solve a
problem that I think technology itself
has created rethink is able to detect
when the combination of keystrokes
creates offensive content are hurtful
words we provide a second chance to
reconsider their decision technology
allows people anywhere to come into
contact with anything it makes
connections it extends people with
powers
it makes things which weren't accessible
accessible feels great that we have the
smartest brains in the country coming
together and solving the problem more
passionately than the founder who
actually started it and would do
anything to make it successful there's
one thing about Playstore that i can
tell you they make sure that you learn
almost every week or every month because
they're themselves making the systems
better and we're all learning together
we didn't know whether this would turn
out to be an innovation that is
impactful and as of today we stand
roughly 7.3 million daily foo bration so
far coding opens doors to make it more
than just an app people everywhere
standing up uniting behind a piece of
technology that they think has the
potential to change the world that's
amazing the next five to ten years are
possibly the most exciting times which
means if you can bring all of them
together collaborate and bring something
to users which really solves a problem
I'm pretty sure that a lot of these
things will form basis to building
better nations in time to come
[Music]